what is the measure of angle C Oh B so
this is C this is oh and this is B so
they're telling us what is the measure
of this angle right over here this is
angle this is angle C OB and they
clearly don't give it to us we need to
figure it out and what they do give us
is they give us the measure of an
adjacent angle this angle this 45-degree
angled angle D Oh C is adjacent because
it shares it shares this arm this this
segment OC with angle C Oh B and then
they give us the combined angle if you
take the two outer arms of the two angle
that these two outer segments if you
look at angle B OD they tell us that
that is 70 degrees so if the measure of
the angle made from these two the two
outer arms of these two adjacent angles
the two outer rays if you kept going out
like this if that's 70 degrees and one
of the adjacent angles is 45 then this
one right over here must be 70 minus 45
or another way of thinking about it is
this angle the question mark angle plus
45 degrees plus 45 degrees must be equal
to 70 degrees must be equal to 70
degrees or that question mark must be
equal to must be equal to 70 degrees
minus 45 degrees minus 45 degrees so
what's this going to be well if it was
70 minus 40 we'd get 230 but then we
have to subtract another five so it's
going to be 25 degrees so the measure of
angle C OB is 25 degrees